今日はドクター始めた
お湯を持つ何がうわーもうなんだこれ前回えーっあっはーんみゃーヌー
あ今山ノクターン済んだん
全部いうやんっ
あ
失礼致しましたはぁ
はいわかりましたという意味合いの前回動いたあいつらとは全く別の新しい入隊を
ズームしましたこんなこと者も同じような感じであの音に反応して真似して動きます
まずはぜひ入れていきましょう
うって言っ
ん
[音楽]
森9ていくはいけてきますはい
[拍手]
[音楽]
ああああああ
ぶーぶーっ
i あの声を真似する性質を利用して人間の声のまではできると思うんです人間じゃ
ない音だったらどれだけ真似できるのか検証してみたいと思います
ブーバすごい草案とかあって私どこまでこんなことができるのが今回検証してみたいと
思いますとりあえずもダイヤモンドを立てると全員 r ちゃんでもう作っているは
ダメだ器具で母子共に招いて検証していきましょう静かに前つけていきます
あああああああああいっ
[音楽]
バーン
me
ええええええ
ん
まあ
he
もう
me
僕を覆った
tan
he ん
re
すごい音に敏感過ぎてマジやばいどうしようこれ
今回並べることが不可能ですちょっと人数絞りますあとは周りで応援してていく
相次ぎで選ばれた先発の6人ですこのメンバーでやりましょうちょっとマジで無理
いるとっ
ああああああっぱいっ
[音楽]
えっこの様へ
wh
[音楽]
voodoo
おっ
[音楽]
ni
[拍手]
はいというわけで多分ウズラはなんか変な雑音みたいな感じで真似は出来ました
次いきますの次薬膳の防犯ブザーです既婚だけ考えようとお話してこの形が学べるか
どうかを見ていきます
ん
[音楽]
いいいいいいいいいい
ni
ずいよいよ最後ですこちら
ドラマ結構低音がパーティ日君でそのドランスをどこで子どもたちにもできるのか
ついていきましょう
乗った
me
ああああああ
ん
[音楽]
pa
me
[拍手]
バッハ
[音楽]
me
dea
car
ana あああっ